for this week's classic interview we
will go back to may of 2014 when i
interviewed Univision host Fernando
espuelas and the topic was how can
Republicans gain minority votes the
context then was about the midterm
election and more generally I think that
this interview really applies to what is
going on now with the Republican Party
Trump implosion and disaster aside
there's this broader issue with the
Republican Party that has been building
for a long time which is you can't rely
overly on white voters because white
voters are a smaller and smaller share
of the electorate every election and I
talked with Fernando about is it even
possible for Republicans to make changes
to attract minority voters let's think
about this in the context of this
upcoming election i'm joined today by
fernando s policies the host and
managing editor of the Fernando espuelas
show on Univision America radio network
it's great to have you on I'll actually
listen to your show which isn't always
the case you know with with a lot of our
guests and it's really cool you actually
do your show partly in Spanish partly in
English how do you decide which parts to
do in which language yeah well thanks so
much for inviting me on your program
well our concept is that Latinos are
predominantly now bilingual and
therefore we can go back and forth when
it makes sense to do so and we will not
lose our audience and in fact that's
what's happened so what we do is we
default Spanish and because it's a
spanish-language network but when we
have callers who are not comfortable
speaking Spanish we switched to English
or when I'm interviewing a political
figure which mostly they don't speak
Spanish we just switch into English and
that's basically the format it totally
depends on what we're talking about and
then there are moments when I forget
Spanish moment so I switched into
English and that seems to work okay as
well well it's it's hugely interesting
to me to do a show that is a political
show that is uh is mostly or at least
part in Spanish because the Hispanic
vote is really becoming increasingly
important and more and more of a topic
of discussion going into the 2016
election and beyond and I've talked
about for years how their demographic
at play in the u.s. right now that are
going to make it really difficult for
Republicans to continue the strategy of
this over reliance on the white vote I
mean looking at 2016 Republicans based
on demographics would need it could be
as much as 60 or 62 percent of the white
vote if they don't gain some of the
non-white vote where do you see this
right now and people you talk to what is
the what is the primary issue that is
keeping Hispanic voters away from voting
for republicans with the exception of
course of cuban-americans which are the
most conservative of the different
Hispanic groups in the US well I'm I
think that I agree with your basic math
that it's increasingly hard to see how
Republicans win the white house without
attracting a much bigger percentage of
the minority vote in general including
african-americans including Asian
Americans but certainly the Hispanic
vote is a critical component because it
is although it's underrepresented in the
voting the overall numbers of potential
voters is huge and it's growing by
50,000 kids who turn 18 every single
month so the issue I think it's a policy
issue i think that the republican party
has shrunk to now be primarily an older
obviously there are other people who
vote for them but generally speaking
that's what is and they've appealed to
this electorate primarily through a
strategy of fear in 2009 if you remember
the Tea Party movement which was
essentially created by consultants in
Washington and then funded by some big
money interest a lot of their messaging
was a give our country back give us our
country back and then bizarre depictions
of Obama's either both a Nazi and a
communist note with no apparent irony
involved so I think that the the overall
demographics change of the country is is
a is a factor I think having an
african-american president is a factor I
think that the Tea Party moving the
center of gravity of the Republican
Party to the far right is the factor
and at the end of the day what's
happened I believe is that you know
Republicans are in favor of immigration
reform if you look at national polling
but when you get into the Congressional
party which has been gerrymandered into
these perfectly hermetically sealed
homogenous congressional districts
mostly that electorate main may not only
not want immigration reform may feel
threatened by it and certainly the
politicians have exploited that fear
with a tremendous cascade of lies about
illegals and they're robbing your job
and and you know they're criminals and
so forth and so on so so I think that
the the problem is that this the
Republican Party does not have today it
seems the will to fundamental evolve its
positions you know they've lost five out
of the six last elections in terms of
popular vote you know that's probably a
signal that your program is not a
program that well can attract a national
majority and but they go through this
process where they decide they have to
change and when it comes to having to
change they default on essentially a
messaging problem we have a messaging
problem but it's not a messaging problem
when you have Mitt Romney in 2012
running on this you know essentially
this the harshest policy possible
self-deportation old ladies and children
out you know will make their lives
impossible until they leave I'm an
American citizen it doesn't impact me
there's no one in my family whose
impacted by a reform but I was highly
insulted by it by that rhetoric and and
certainly the premise that you would be
able to attract supporters not just
among Hispanics but among Americans
independence and and center Republicans
to what is uh you know vaguely 1930s
policy of displacement of 12 million
people I mean just make some sense I
think that there may also be another
factor at play here always lurking in
the background of all of these positions
is the effect on fundraising right
because fundraising because of our our
how elections are financed here are our
fundraising is is at the forefront is it
possible that Republicans realize that
they need to
their positions on on immigration maybe
adopting something closer to what Jeb
Bush talked about recently saying you
know it's just not really feasible to
say we're going to deport everybody we
should institute some kind of path to
citizenship but at the same time they
realize that their base which is very
much against anything even resembling
amnesty may stop donating money to them
if they adopt that policy you know I'm
not sure that's because the party from
my perspective anyway it seems to be
divided among the grass roots which are
primarily blue class workers you know
older downscale lower education levels
and then the so-called establishment
which are primarily business interests
and the business interests like for
example the US Chamber of Commerce which
has been essentially an annex of the
Republican Party for decades they're
completely in favor of immigration
reform and why because it's very
beneficial to business and I think if
you pull back what is immigration reform
forget the emotions it is a fundamental
shift in how we have to structure our
country in order to be competitive for
the next 100 years if you just were to
freeze magically the population that is
in the country today no more immigrants
legal illegal doesn't matter you would
in fact have a declining population
about 30 years from now set in another
way we would have a declining national
economy a political structure but our
ability to project power internationally
would go away I mean there are a lot of
really fundamental issues here that
immigration addresses you know and then
you can go up and down the scale you can
go to Silicon Valley and how you know
that engine of tremendous innovation
really requires lots of immigrants that
we want to be able to Hoover up the the
best minds of the in the world and have
them come here without all the hassle or
if they're coming to our universities to
have them stay here and then all the way
on the other side of the labor market
the reality of it is and this was put to
the test in Alabama with the
anti-immigrant law there and Georgia at
the same way that without immigrants who
are essentially willing to
do some very hard work that other people
are not willing to do the agricultural
sector suffers tremendously and then
there's everyone else in the middle
right so so I think the issue ultimately
is about ideology more than money and
and I think that the the it's impossible
seemingly at least that's what Romney
experienced to win the Republican
nomination without taking this extremist
position and let's remember Mitt Romney
of all the people on planet earth who he
what he could have picked to be his
immigration advisor he picked Crisco
Bosh who was the author of the Alabama
anti-immigrant law the Arizona
anti-immigrant law who has been writing
voter ID laws to exclude Hispanics and
who can be traced to a group of white
supremacist organizations no I'm not
exaggerating it if you look at John tent
and the John Canton network there's a
great New York Times piece that's worth
reading where it actually puts out all
this these huge groups of supposedly
independent activists or in fact all
connected behind one strategy which is
to stop all immigration into this
country so I mean that was that was Mitt
Romney's choice and and I think that
whatever else you think about his
politics I don't think he's in fact I
think he's a very smart man and and but
at the end of the day in order to get
even close to winning the nomination he
had to assume some of these positions
which were ultimately completely
unpalatable to well Hispanic certainly
but asian-americans he they'd lost the
asian american vote by you know even a
bigger margin than than the hispanic
vote Fernando espuelas Fernando is
fellas show on Univision American radio
network what's the best way for people
around the country to listen to your
show well if you have a Univision
America station in your city that's one
way but probably the best way is to
listen online you can listen to my show
live on euphoria which is a nap on a
Univision app you can download for
whatever phone platform you can also
listen to iHeartRadio online and also
Univision america.com streams the show
as well it's on for
224 eastern time monday thru friday and
then it's all across the country
excellent fernando you're from enugu I
i'm from argentina i'm very excited for
the world cup which is which is going to
be happening soon how are things looking
for your country this time around well i
think of you know I'm the one Uruguayan
who does not follow soccer so so you
know Argentina then I'm gonna root for
the United States and and Uruguay as
well in Argentine you know at the end of
the day I learned early on that I will
not attach my emotions to a bunch of
guys who may or may not win and I cannot
control so I'm not into the heartbreak
experience of the world cup but I
certainly will watch the finals all
right Fernando really a pleasure having
you on thanks for doing it thank David a
pleasure being with you thanks for
inviting me